in Odessa when someone's house settles
oddly or their water line breaks or
their pet goes missing it's not uncommon
for them to curse those goddamned
catacombs underneath Odessa is the
largest catacomb system in the world
with over a thousand miles of unexplored
tunnels and a total length of 2,500
kilometers that is more than the
distance from Odessa to Paris from the
end of the 1700s on people have been
mining and quarrying limestone out of
these catacombs both legitimately and
illegitimately the catacombs also became
the preferred hideout of eccentrics
smugglers criminals of any kind and
during the wars especially world war ii
huge groups of soldiers lived in these
catacombs for over a year in the 1960s
they became home to catacomb explorers
every year the founding catacombs
exploration group called poised for the
search performs a huge mapping
expedition they took 40 people below
ground they cooked dinner down there
they spent four days underneath the
surface of Odessa and they map an
unexplored part of the catacombs but
it's slow work it's 10 20 30 kilometers
at a time which at 30 kilometers a year
they should be finished in about 30
years the catacombs of course for these
explorers are dangerous places in 2005 a
group of Ukrainian teenagers went into
the catacombs
to celebrate New Years they were hanging
out they were drinking and a young girl
named Masha wandered off and they
couldn't find her in fact the catacombs
are so large they didn't retrieve her
body for two years the catacombs are a
problem for Odessa people are channeling
their sewage directly into the catacombs
which makes exploring them potentially
extremely gross that sewage weakens the
limestone and can cause the tunnels to
cave in left to their own devices
they're all gonna slowly dissolve taking
down at the city of Odessa with them
click here to subscribe or click here to
watch our other videos the Dungeons &
Dragons player in me is obsessed with
these this is a dungeon crawl you know
it's what you would draw on your graph
paper for your dungeon crawl that is
what the Odessa catacombs actually are
tunnels and tunnels and tunnels and
tunnels and what do you think the
world's greatest hidden wonders are let
me know in the comments and I can't wait
to hear all about them